[music]
[applause]
[music] [
music]
[ __ ] oop
op uh [ __ ]
ah
date
[music]
Russian military personnel the
commander of the second assault
battalion of the third separate assault
brigade of the Armed Forces of Ukraine is addressing you my
call sign slip it’s been 24 hours since our guys
occupied the entire village of Andreevka  your
personnel either fled from the battlefield or were
destroyed
[music]
and we offer you to surrender for one
simple reason. We need an exchange fund,
if you have not expressed such a desire, we will
destroy you all; the desire for skill and
everything else for this we have more
than enough
If  you will surrender, I as an officer promise
that they will leave you alive, give you something to eat, they
will not mock you and soon you
will end up in the exchange fund to think about it, we
give you 10
[music]
minutes
K [music
]
[music]
on Andreevka
our
Y